[Music]
on this friday night amplifying calls
for accountability after finding
hundreds of unmarred grades residential
school survivors keep
looking for answers i was taken from my
family when i was three years old
the demands for atonement from the
church and the government
what the fully vaccinated can and cannot
do some guidelines are released but the
messaging is confusing
derek shovin sentenced for murder the
emotional impact statements
from george floyd's family if you could
say anything to your daddy right now
what would it be
the relentless mission to find survivors
under a collapsed
florida condo we're not giving up at all
and hockey hangover montreal cleans up
as the canadians gear up to bring home
the stanley cup
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in saskatchewan where a
field next to the site of a former
residential school
is now sacred ground believed to be the
site of at least
600 possibly as many as 751 unmarked
graves
the largest discovery of its kind in
this country
there was an apology and there were more
promises from the prime minister today
we'll get to that in just a moment
but we begin by hearing from people from
the causes first nation
about what they want heather yorick's
west is near that first nation tonight
and has our top story heather
emotions are so raw here in saskatchewan
sadness but a lot of anger too this
discovery did not come as a shock to the
people here
but it has renewed the call for
accountability
on the doors of saint paul co-cathedral
in downtown saskatoon
the rage is clear we were children the
graffiti reads in blood red paint
vandalism that took place thursday on
the same day the calluses first nation
announced the discovery of as many as
751 people in
unmarked graves outside the site of the
former maryvale indian residential
school there's a lot of layers to this
and i you know if i i might say
you know this is a long-term process and
um
anger is legitimate you know anger and
it needs to be
heard and you can't force someone
through their anger
and all that is with it i was taken from
my family when i was three years old
gracia perkins spent six years at the
school her earliest memories filled with
abuse
as punishment she says she was often
locked in a dark
closet alone it was terrifying
to be locked in that dark broom closet
how old were you for years she suspected
children were buried on the site
her own cousin was killed in an accident
at the school
discovering the graves she says is
important for everyone
very important because
i remember looking at those swings in
the summertime
in the evening and it was just calm out
and those swings would always be
swinging
just like little kids were playing on
there but perkins is looking for
accountability and
answers from the church as well the
missionary of oblates of mary immaculate
ran dozens of residential schools
including the ones on kawasa's first
nation
and in kamloops it has still not
disclosed all of its historical
documents
in a statement it says it has worked to
make our historical documents available
but progress has been complicated by
issues of provincial and national
privacy laws
every single document has to be
accessible
uh in order to properly identify
children
know where they went because not all
graves are going to be known
leaving communities to grieve with each
new discovery
members of the cowas first nation plan
to gather at the site of the unmarked
graves for a community vigil on saturday
night there is just so much grief here
for families and while there is a need
for time and space to heal
there are also a lot of questions that
need to be answered
too donna all right heather yorick's
west near the kaoasis first nation in
saskatchewan
thanks prime minister justin trudeau
says canadians are horrified and ashamed
that for decades the federal government
forcibly removed indigenous children
from their homes
and sent them to boarding schools to
have their language and culture erased
but strong words and more promises don't
change the fact
most of the 94 calls to action laid out
six years ago
in the truth and reconciliation
commission report have not been acted on
michael couture is also looking into
accountability tonight
it is not exactly news
for indigenous peoples while the
discovery of more graves on the site of
a former residential school
is devastating prime minister justin
trudeau says it shouldn't shock people
because it was clearly laid out in the
final report of the truth and
reconciliation commission
10 years ago in 2009 the harper
government denied funding
to find grades more than a decade later
after the discovery in kamloops bc
the liberals said 27 million dollars
would be available
immediately for that purpose indigenous
communities across this country have my
commitment that they will get the
resources necessary
to recover and document
as much as possible
these kids in these graves unmarked
graves account for five of the 94
calls to action from the commission some
indigenous leaders feel the lack of
progress on
all calls to action since the liberals
have been in power
is troubling romeo saginaws had it right
when he said that the liberal government
doesn't
doesn't care down about indigenous
people
and doesn't know anything
of substance about what it is that we
need
that includes an apology from the pope
and more than just an acknowledgement
from the catholic church
which ran many of the residential
schools in canada
i think they should be compelled and
brought to court even
for their role in what happened to
to our our loved ones the president of
the canadian conference of catholic
bishops
says the church is cooperating with
supplying documents
and in organizing a meeting in rome
between the pope
and canadian indigenous leaders three
days
in rome you know when heads of state
only have 15 minutes or half an hour
the pope is dedicated one hour for each
one of those
uh indigenous realities plus a time for
coming together all together another
hour on top of that
and donna the prime minister reiterated
today any papal apology
should take place on canadian soil mike
i want to ask you about carolyn bennett
the minister of crown indigenous
relations who was accused yesterday
by her former colleague jody
wilson-raybould of sending a racist
demeaning text the union of bc indian
chiefs called it a
cowardly attempt to silence a powerful
indigenous voice
they want bennett to resign is the prime
minister standing by her
well he basically said she's not going
anywhere prime minister trudeau
did acknowledge what minister bennett
did was wrong
and he accepted her apology i know
carolyn's heart i know how hard she has
worked for
decades on this issue and i know how
much more
there is for us all to do and i know
that she
understands how much
more work she's going to have to do in
the coming days weeks and months
donna that's a pretty clear signal he
intends to keep bennett in his cabinet
and in this key role
all right mike lookatura thanks there is
support for those
who need it the indian residential
school survivors crisis line is
available in canada 24 hours
a day the number is toll free you can
speak in confidence
the number is 1-866-925-4419
now to the pandemic new federal modeling
is warning the highly transmissible
delta variant
could make a possible fourth wave worse
it's why there's been such a push to get
people
vaccinated more than 76 percent of
eligible canadians have now received at
least one shot
26 percent are fully vaccinated and
today
new federal guidelines about what fully
vaccinated canadians are allowed to do
were quietly released eric sorensen
reports we apologize that the
tools were not ready it was an awkward
rollout
but the public health agency of canada
has finally produced guidelines for
canadians
depending on their vaccination status if
you are fully vaccinated you no longer
need a mask or to physically distance
in most outdoor settings and indoor
settings with small groups
you can also consider not having masks
or distancing
indoors with larger groups or outdoor
large gatherings like
concerts unless you have health risks
for those not
vaccinated or partially vaccinated no
mask or distancing is needed for small
groups outside
you could consider mask removal and not
distancing for some indoor and outdoor
gatherings
but you should still wear a mask and
physically distance
if you are inside with multiple
households or say outdoors at a crowded
concert
i think we needed some guidance i hope
that people anticipate
that that is going to change over time
and we'll learn as we go good to see
some guidance though people have been
looking for it
so the restrictions are easing for
indoor and outdoor gatherings and will
be safer the more people get their shots
the urgency now is to have canadians
fully vaccinated
those older than 60 have a very high
uptake of first doses up to 90 percent
or higher
under the age of 40 it's still below 70
percent second doses
shows a similar pattern older canadians
are getting their second shots but for
those under age 30
fewer than 10 percent have received
second doses and that is a worry
young adults are more likely to be in
work or social gatherings in larger
numbers and run the risk of causing a
surge in cases this fall or winter
with the highly transmissible delta
variant still spreading
it does make a difference they are the
highest
um transmitters because they have an
increased social mixing the incentives
for getting vaccinated by now
should be clear almost all the cases and
certainly almost all the deaths are in
the unvaccinated people
that the lesson is clear vaccination is
our way out of this
if you're not vaccinated you remain
vulnerable and susceptible and as new
guidelines suggest
life can return to normal but how normal
depends on how well vaccinated we
are eric sorensen global news toronto
more ontarians will soon be eligible to
book a second vaccine dose
earlier starting on saturday youth age
12 to 17 who live in delta variant hot
spots can book dose number two and on
monday all adults who received a first
dose of an mrna vaccine either pfizer or
moderna
can book their second shot according to
the province this will accelerate second
dose eligibility for about
one and a half million people in the u.s
one of the most watched murder cases in
history
is over derek chovin the former
minneapolis police officer
convicted of killing george floyd has
been sentenced to 22 and a half years in
prison
that's less time than prosecutors had
asked for
far more though than chauvin's defense
had wanted jackson proskow is outside
the courthouse tonight jackson how are
people reacting
well donna this is one of the stiffest
sentences against a police officer for
unauthorized use of lethal force on the
job
and for the floyd family and for many of
the people here in minneapolis
it's the beginning of the accountability
they've been looking for
and for the defense good afternoon your
honor for murdering george floyd
former police officer derrick chauvin
will spend the next two decades of his
life in prison
i want to acknowledge the deep
and tremendous pain that all the
families are feeling especially the
floyd family
it concludes one of the most watched
trials in american history
that brought the rare conviction of an
on-duty police officer
in a case that sparked an international
movement for racial justice
if you could say anything to your daddy
right now what would it be
it would be i miss you and i love you
inside the court floyd's family
delivered emotional impact statements
about the man they lost and about the
horror they witnessed
the certain murder of george has forever
traumatized us
you may see us cry but the full extent
of our pain and trauma
will never be seen with the naked eye
floyd's family had asked for the maximum
possible sentence while derek chovin's
mother broke her
long-standing silence to plead for
leniency when you sentence
my son he will also be sentencing me
shovin spoke briefly to hint at a future
appeal
but offered no apology or remorse before
being sentenced
do you want to give my condolences to
the floyd family
outside members of the community
expressed anger at the less than maximum
sentence but also relief at seeing
accountability
you know this is a small victory for you
know our community right now i feel like
you know the sentence could have been
a little bigger but one year i guess is
better than no year
chauvin is likely to spend 15 years in
prison
before becoming eligible for parole in
his brief remarks today
he hinted at a future appeal and
suggested more information will come to
light that he believes will bring
comfort to the floyd family
donna jackson prosco in minneapolis
tonight thanks
the florida condo that crumbled as
residents slept coming up still no sign
of dozens of people possibly
including canadians
in florida it's now becoming clear many
of those who were inside that 12-story
condo that partially collapsed are
unlikely to be found alive
global affairs canada says they've
received reports indicating canadian
citizens
may be affected but they're not offering
any more information than that
the search is still underway and it is
painstaking
a wing of the condo all 12 stories
pancaked to the ground
rescue workers are struggling to safely
access the site they're dealing with
small
fires and rain teams are forming bucket
brigades to remove rubble piece by piece
others are digging from below looking
and listening for any signs of life
a state of emergency has been declared
at least four people are known to have
died and
160 are unaccounted for
we know that people can't survive for
extended period times
under the rubble so we you know we're
going to keep on going until we're told
you know time's up
it is unclear what caused the 40 year
old building to collapse
scientists have long been concerned
about the shifting sands of miami beach
especially with rising sea levels
the building had also recently undergone
work to its roof
still ahead i speak with an expert about
the sensitive nature of searching
for unmarked graves
indigenous families know about children
who never came home from school who died
far away in what were called residential
schools in most cases the bodies would
not be sent home
unless the family paid for it and so
here we are decades later finding these
unmarked graves causing families to be
traumatized all over again finding the
graves
is hard work both technically and
emotionally
with me is kisha supernan she is
director of the institute of prairie and
indigenous
archaeology at the university of alberta
kisha this is such
sensitive work on so many levels because
ground penetrating radar
involves walking over the graves can you
help us understand the intensive
sensitive nature of the work yes it is
extremely
difficult work so there's of course the
technical elements of ensuring that
we're doing
all this work to the highest possible
standard but being out in these places
often means hearing the stories of
survivors and
families and then starting to get those
traces and hints of
the possible burial places of these
children who never came home
it is very emotionally devastating and
difficult work to do
as we walk across the graves of these
children and each community of course
will make their own decisions about the
next steps
when graves are found but can you
explain what's involved if they decide
to go ahead and identify the remains and
give them a proper burial
i think this is a really big and
important question uh so
the work that we've primarily done has
been remote sensing and finding the
locations to take it to the next step
involves really a form of forensic
investigation and that can involve
exclamation potentially using techniques
such as dna
to uh try to identify these children and
connect them with
living relatives sometimes that's
possible sometimes that's not
that's quite a time intensive process if
that is
the next steps that a community wants to
take and then there's also a call for
justice and accountability
and there are forensic approaches which
can look at
potential signs uh of any remains that
of you know trauma or things like that
but that itself
it's a big unknown we don't know what
the the state of the remains necessarily
are we don't know how many answers can
be found
and i want to emphasize i think a lot of
communities that might not be a step
they're ready or willing to take
it might be enough to know where these
locations are to do the historical
research and then to commemorate
and do ceremony around these these
sacred places so we'll have to see how
communities wish to approach it but it
would be a more forensic investigation
should there be more work beyond the the
kind of ground penetrating radar
are there enough people in this country
with the expertise and the experience to
do this kind of work even the ground
penetrating radar for all the sites that
that might exist
not in the timelines that i think many
communities are hoping for
there just are a small handful of people
with experience on the ground
penetrating radar side
uh there's a you know not that many more
that might have capacity on the forensic
side
and i think there's a role potentially
for
a private industry to play to play a
role here especially on the ground
penetrating radar
but it has to be done to the highest
technical standards
and there are some best practices that
we've established i know there's also
been conversations about potentially
engaging
with internationals or task forces and
groups who have done
forensic work at the scale that might be
required
so i think there's a lot to sort out
about how we can actually meet
the needs of communities from a capacity
standpoint and hopefully build some of
that capacity within communities where
appropriate
what do you think canadians should
expect to hear about this story in the
months and years ahead
well i hope that there's a continued
attention to
these stories as they come out from
every
residential school in the country and of
course
communities will decide how much they
want to make public the information and
in which ways
but i think we can expect more kamloops
more calluses
and thousands more graves of children
across the lands we call canada
kisha supernan director of the institute
of prairie and indigenous archaeology
thanks for joining us
thank you for having me
we the north next the habs make it to
the stanley cup finals and some fans
lose it
we're all habs fans now right there was
jubilation when the montreal canadiens
scored that overtime goal beating the
las vegas golden knights and sealing
their spot
in the stanley cup final not only is it
the first time the halves have made it
to the finals since winning the cup in
1993 it's the first time any canadian
team has made it this far in a decade
and it happened on quebec's fete
nationale holiday
big crowds gathered outside the bell
center social distancing non-existent
they went wild after that winning goal
and then some fans took things
way too far
[Applause]
over a dozen arrests were made eight
police vehicles were damaged two
officers suffered minor injuries
in the end police used tear gas to
disperse the crowds
fans are now gearing up for the finals
who montreal plays will be decided in
tonight's game between the new york
islanders and the tampa bay lightning
and the first game of the final is
monday june 28th in either
tampa or new york something to look
forward to and that is global national
for this friday i'm donna friesen
everyone's jumping on the bandwagon now
even the animals
flambo is the service dog the team
fostered while he was undergoing his
training
and there are plenty of pups who are
haves fans
a few cats too there should be cats of
course
i think i'm a cat fan thanks for
watching robin gill will be here at the
anchor desk this weekend
i'll see you again on monday take care
of yourselves bye bye
you